i hope this works
happy wednesday everyone we have a great
show tonight judge jeanine
is joining us
and
and why not i have pictures of her
do you know it's illegal to ride poodles
dressed up as a cowgirl
that's checking all right
but we're also gonna try something out
here we're breaking new ground it's time
for
scratch and sniff monologue
this has never been done and probably
for good reason
but it's true at any moment you dear
viewer will be asked to scratch the tv
screen
when an image appears and then you have
to guess what that image smells like
i know there's something wrong with me
there's something wrong with me but
isn't this fun it's a special treat for
all of you at home and for our fans
watching for free at best buy
so let's go to the first one
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right huh
oh yeah there you go the scratch and
snip all right get up there get up your
screen smell it smell it smell your
fingers oh get up there
all right what's that smell like what's
that's about now if you guessed parmesan
cheese you win
very good but we will accept crisco
because we know he does
disgusting all right according to new
leaked audio obtained by the washington
examiner hunter claims his dad viewed
him as a god and if that's not an
argument for atheism what is
but hunter could be confused every time
he called his dad to tell him what kind
of trouble he was in joe would say oh
god what did you do now
the recording was stored on that laptop
we were told was russian disinformation
by this lady
remember her
all right get up there get up there you
get two seconds to smell her what does
she smell like does she smell like a new
career
you're right but we would have taken
russian dressing
anyway
let's go to hunter i wonder if we'll
talk about anything
we'll talk about um anything that i
wanted to that he believes in if i say
this is important to me
then he will work a way in which to make
it a part of his of his platform the man
i most admire in the world
that god to me
thinks i'm a god
and my brother did too
and the three of us
it was literally i had the support to
know i can do anything
yeah including his brother's wife
anyway
hunter claims his dad would do anything
he said which must have made the hookers
very nervous
speaking of pop
here you go
all right
what's that smell like get up really
close take a deep whiff is it disaster
is it incompetence
how about a loaded pair of depends and
some polygraph
well yesterday put on quite a show at
the afl-cio with every clip more viral
than a bucket full of monkey pox
which by the way is the new ben and
jerry's flavor
but he doesn't want to hear any more of
these lies
i don't want to hear any more of these
lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
yeah
we're changing people's lives that's
true actually my neighbor phil now
demands to be called phyllis
we're actually closer now yesterday went
bra shopping with him it's difficult but
if joe is changing people's lives how is
that a positive
polio changed lives too
i'm not saying joe is like polio
or am i you are am i it doesn't matter
because i bet his plan is simple my plan
is simple
first
i'm doing everything in my power
to blunt putin's gas price height it's
going to take time but let the world
coordinate the largest release what i've
been able to do
the largest release
of oil and from the global
fund in history
he didn't even like the only the
sentences he started with i'm done
i mean that was a mess and it wasn't
true but okay because his plan isn't
finished like that sentence and the
results aren't finished either
that's why my plan is not finished
why the results aren't finished either
the results aren't finished that's the
same thing the plastic surgeon said
about michael jackson's face
oh what too soon
it's the only thing that remains
so what's his solution for a flailing
economy i bet all he's asking for is for
the largest corporations and wealthiest
americans to pay their fair share all
i'm asking is for the largest
corporations and the wealthiest
americans
to begin to pay their fair share in
taxes
yeah we wouldn't mind paying our fair
share if we weren't already but he's
right paying five dollars a gallon for
gasoline and six dollars a pound for
hamburger isn't fair at all to us i
always knew living in new york i'd
eventually get mugged i just didn't
think it would be my by my butcher
and by the way since when is raising
taxes a solution for inflation we're
already getting taxed by rising prices
and now you want to add more it's like
he has only one tool to fix 20 different
problems he's a proctologist whose only
medical instrument is a hand grenade
you know at least he's not coughing
[Applause]
i'm not joking
yeah last time i coughed like that i was
being checked for a hernia by kevin
spacey
sorry no doubt joe's been exposed to
covet 19 but it's coveted 18 19.
but america still has a choice to make
america still has a choice to make
true do we impeach you now or invoke the
25th amendment and what about those
better paying jobs better paying jobs
for better jobs for them and their
families
it's been a long time since that's
happened in this country yeah a long
time you gotta hearken all the way back
to
2020.
oh those were the days
so why is everything so bad now well
instead of focusing on the economy his
woke white house targeted parents at
school boards elevated identity over
education made sure every job
appointment was a historic first and a
historic worst instead of prioritizing
competence and now under biden even
tampons are in short supply if that's
not a war on women i'm joy behar
and how do you know
that i'm not
we could pass for twins if i stop
shaving my back
but that doesn't affect joe cause
nothing does he's just along for the
ride and he's not even driving and
that's why as gas prices soar it's also
not his problem the last time he was
behind the wheel it was when a secret
service member pulled him around the
white house grounds and a red wagon
so we got a president who not only does
not feel your pain he's not even
thinking about it only one thing at a
time and that thing is usually how do i
climb the stairs
he's no figure for a crisis
look i know my limitations if i'm at a
party and you need some drinks i'll make
them but if someone starts choking i'd
be as useless as dr jill biden
in that kind of emergency i'll disappear
quicker than jessie waters when the
check arrives
we need someone to throw us a lifesaver
here not a dumb dumb huh
i wonder what joe has to say
hey come on man look look i'm sick and
tired of it man look i know some things
are more expensive gas and but some
things are less expensive you got to
look around
and i mean look at this my pillow i just
got this guy's having a two for one he's
practically giving them away and uh
have you priced lp records lately look
at this they used to cost 10 bucks 1.50
on ebay all right mucho mucho man they
get they get everything on there all
right that's a little over a dollar how
about this 99 cents cher's greatest hits
look i think she was better after she
left ike turner
[Music]
let's welcome tonight's guests
criminals asked bayless to protect them
from her co-host of the five judge
janine bureau
he's so chiseled michelangelo is jealous
host of can't cancel bob rob smith rob
smith
she once got a noise complaint from an
air horn fox news contributor cat tip
and his jumping jacks register on the
richter scale my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion tyrus
judge welcome to the show thank you you
look very well pollinated well thank you
what does that mean you like my flowers
yeah i like your flowers
they're blooming
that's
enough it is enough judge welcome to the
show how did you like the scratch and
sniff segment
that was an experiment yeah i'll tell
you the most disgusting though was joe
biden i mean that was really scary yes
exactly what's going on judge what are
we doing no who what uh our country is
it what do we do
you have all these people bringing it
look look he look it's all russia's
fault it's all putin's fault but you
know what the problem is what we only
got eight percent of our oil from putin
and then with the ukraine war it we cut
down to nothing but yet everything's
still putin's fault that he's stupid or
duh or crazy i don't know which one it
is that is true it's only like eight
percent that makes sense it's less than
that now but since it's a war yeah not
crazy
he's pointing fingers and i hate it when
they point fingers rob especially when
they're at me yeah interesting i think
the interesting thing about uh the
hunter biden stuff is that the man that
hunter biden thinks or excuse me the uh
man that joe biden thinks is a god is a
crackhead which actually explains a lot
of these policies are coming out of this
administration and then when you you
watch joe biden it's like he's got two
different things either he's screaming
at you or he's doing that creepy little
whisper which i'm glad didn't happen but
it's almost like he is that that meme of
that old man yelling at a crowd he at a
cloud he is literally abraham simpson
that is who he is at this point
i haven't thought of a old abe simpson
in quite a while yeah one of my favorite
simpsons after oj of course
tyrus well that's everybody's favorite
simpson
everybody's got a favorite simpson
ashley yeah
anyway
why did that come into my brain
uh uh what does it think was the scratch
and sniff give it a rating do you think
it should be done again or should it be
buried and forgotten i think it should
be done on mondays i think it'd be a
great
thing on mondays uh i'll watch it from
home
we'll try it out and tell you how it
works so and i'll text you afterwards oh
because you're not on the show on
mondays yeah
um
you can ask me a question about this or
you just want to you know why do you get
the impression that democratic politics
are all about knowing what's better for
you and you don't know what's better for
yourself so they can get away with all
of the austerity austerity programs like
high gas prices well that in the end
that's good for you because it's going
to lower your gas consumption i i think
we're getting kind of the you can
combine the the honor byron situation
with his policies yeah
it's bad parenting
[Music]
across the board now he's not
responsible for his son's actions but he
is responsible for enabling his son's
actions exactly if you're a parent and
your child is
young as an adult and he's a drug addict
you don't keep throwing more money on it
you cut him off right that's true
you publicly let everyone know he has a
problem you stepped down from office to
take care of your family as a senator
you should have been doing that
and you never should have ran for
president knowing the issues that one of
your own child has and he's now made him
a target
you take that how is he governing how is
he running this country what is he doing
there's a problem
he takes our money and throws it on it
yeah
and he can keep pulling it and throwing
on it so
forget all the
espionage and right right-wing stuff
whatever
our president's a bad parent and he's
running our country like a bad parent
and that's why everything's expensive
and we're all struggling excellent i
would like to get emancipated yes
[Applause]
i am going to be a great parent by not
having children
yes
think about my non-kids are going to
thank me like thank god wherever they
are
you know uh kat uh let's be honest uh of
all the people in this uh in this studio
we know that hunter was on coke exactly
like in that conversation yes so i
many things can always be true at once
it's obvious there's some corruption
going on in the biden family it's
equally obvious that that recording
sounds like every man ever on cocaine
if you know if if you did a study of
things that people say when they've been
coked out for days
i can do anything
and like he thinks i'm god right are
probably right at the top and his voice
is all raspy he sounds like he's been
tough in drugs for quite a while
so i don't doubt that even if none of it
were true he'd probably be feeling it i
mean people who are coked out tend to
have high estimations of their business
abilities that's what makes him so
dangerous in one way is that he wouldn't
shut up which is what coke heads do is
they never stop talking they'll talk
about anything judge they'll talk about
their screenplay by the way so i have
this idea yes
half judge half robot oh fighting aliens
on an undiscovered planet that's inside
earth
okay i have no idea what you're talking
about
but what i want is what i want to ask is
how come the two of you know so much
about what it's like to be coked up they
watch a lot of a andes
no you know why he wrote a thesis
because they watched the hunter biden
documentary on fox nation
wait a minute who narrated that
documentary i did and i don't know what
they did okay i volunteer with
underprivileged tenants
because i don't want to brag and also
for a story like this
people journalists real journalists like
me have to do research
right you have to get into the head yeah
of a coke head yeah right yep he has an
office full of them right now
interviewing him every week and i spent
my life putting people like
that not you in jail ah well you know
what what you missed this little guy
i crawled right through the little
orders out the aliens don't worry about
it you know what that was a long time
ago the big story here is they covered
up this story to win an election that's
the big story you wonder why there was a
you know rally january 6 is because
people intuited is that a word yes
that's true why not yes i'll take that
things were corrupt
all right up next biden goes to great
pains to blame it on border agents
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else